euh fin mars je reçois un coup de
téléphone de monsieur cifaoui me disant
qu'il sortait du bureau de la ministre
délégué qui lui présentait le projet en
perspective
et lui-même relatant le fait qu'il était
pleinement satisfait de savoir qui
allait avoir un projet de ce type là
avec
des subventions permettant justement de
porter des projets d'envergure dans le
champ qu'on évoque depuis le début
je sais aussi qu'il y a eu des réunions
c'est ce qu'il m'avait dit à l'époque
avec effectivement le cabinet de la
ministre déléguée
sur peut-être d'autres sujets aussi bien
sûr puisque encore une fois c'est un
expert reconnu mais probablement les
mêmes personnes que celles que vous avez
évoquées tout à l'heure
oui c'était parce que de toute façon
c'était ces personnes là qui suivaient
ces sujets là donc en toute logique et
donc voilà le fin mars l'appelle que je
reçois
précisant ce qui se trame avec le fond
Marianne à très court terme et le fait
que
on lui a demandé de réfléchir à un
projet
ambitieux en fait il est mis dans les
starting blocks on lui demande de
candidater avant même le c'est
clairement ce qu'il me dit il me dit
clairement que un c'est une bonne
nouvelle et donc évidemment il va il va
il va s'engager dans ce projet là et
vous l'avez vérifié auprès du cabinet
tout de suite enfin je veux dire vous
avez le cabinet qui vous dit je vais le
faire au nom de la ministre je fais
simple pour rappel le cabinet pour
savoir de quoi il retourne le cabinet on
a quelques jours plus tard réunion et on
est début avril et là on commence à
parler du fond Marianne donc c'est là où
je comprends que tout ça est en train de
cette manière là et le projet de
Monsieur Sifaoui est évoqué à plusieurs
reprises je vous rappelle qu'il est
évoqué à l'occasion du comité de
programmation du du 13 donc voilà